واسئله مجددا والجيش الروسي التقليديه فما
نحاول الان قراءه ملخص لبن
عسكرياسه السخان اقوى
[موسيقى]
فعليا لخوض مواجهه مع الغرب وهو لما يحسم
المعركه مع اوكرانيا ما حقيقه عظمه الجيش
الروسي المرسومه في اذهان كثيرين
يعد الجيش الروسي ثاني اقوى جيوش العالم
بعد الجيش الامريكي بحسب مؤشر جلوبال فاير
باور المتخصص بالشؤون العسكريه يتفوق
بقوته على الجيش الصيني الاكبر في العالم
من حيث العدد والثاني من حيث الميزانيه
[موسيقى]
عرف الجيش الروسي بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي الكثير من التغيرات نتيجه
التحولات السياسيه واستقلال الدول التي
كانت تخضع لسلطته بعضها ما يزال يكن
العداء لموسكو تحولات ادت الى تراجع قدرات
الجيش وعديده وبرامج تدريبات افراده
وتطوير سلاحه ومع تفكك الاتحاد السوفيتي
وزعت تشكيلات القوات الجويه على الدول
المستقله فحصلت روسيا على النصيب الاكبر
بواقع 40% من الطائرات وخمسه وستين في
المئه من القوه البشريه بالاضافه الى
قيادات سرب النقل الجوي بعيد المدى يقدر
عدد المجندين الروسي حاليا بثلاثه ملايين
وخمسمائه الف جندي وتبلغ ميزانيه الدفاع
ومعدل الانفاق السنوي للجيش 42 مليار
دولار يمتلك الجيش الروسي 4,1
73 طائره قتاليه
و445 طائره نقل
و52 طائره تدريب
و122 طائره مهمات خاصه اما المروحيات فيصل
عددها الى
يقدر عدد الدبابات باثنتي عشره الف
واربعمائه وعشرين مقابل ثلاثين الف ومائه
واثنان وعشرين مركبه مصفحه وسته الاف
وخمسمائه واربعه وسبعين مدفعيه ذاتيه
الحركه وثلاثه الاف وثلاثمائه واحد وتسعين
قذيفه صواريخ متنقله وقبل كل ذلك مخزون
الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه الذي يعد الاكبر
في العالم
حقق العتاد الروسي تميزا كبيرا اسهم في
رسم السياسه الخارجيه لموسكو على مدى
عقدين تقريبا ولا سيما ابان غزل جورج عام
والحرب في منطقه دومباس منذ عام 2014
والتدخل في سوريا عام 2015
وساعدت التدريبات العسكريه واسعه النطاق
في فوستوك على الحفاظ على صوره اسطوره جيش
حديث وقوي ومستعد للتدخل في اي نزاع مهما
كانت صعوبته
[موسيقى]
هذا ما يروج له اعلاميا لكن على ارض
الواقع يرى خبراء عسكريون ان هذه الصوره
ليست حقيقيه وخصوصا بعد الحرب التي شنتها
موسكو في اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين من
شباط فبراير 2022 اذ كانت الخطه الروسيه
تهدف الى الاطاحه بحكومه كييف خلال ايام
او اسابيع وهو ما لم يتحقق حتى اللحظه
اثبت الجيش الروسي بحسب مايكل ريبس
الجنرال الامريكي الذي عمل مع اوكرانيا
سنوات طويله انه اقل فعاليه بكثير مما
توقعه البعض ويرجع السبب في ذلك الى
المركبات الروسيه سيئه الصيانه ومعنويات
الجنود المنخفضه جدا
مايكل كيمج استاذ التاريخ بالجامعه
الكاثوليكيه الامريكيه يرى بدوره ان الجيش
الروسي في اوكرانيا اظهر ضعفا في التخطيط
وسوءا في التنظيم وذهب الى ان حرب موسكو
في اوكرانيا كان القصد منها ان تكون اعظم
انجازات الرئيس بوتين ودليلا على ما وصلت
اليه بلاده من تقدم منذ انهيار
الامبراطوريه السوفياتيه عام
وكان من المفترض ان يكون ضم اوكرانيا خطوه
اولى في اعاده بناء امبراطوريه الروسيه
لكن الرياح جرت بما لم تشتهيه سفن الروسيه
اذ اثبت النظام السياسي في روسيا بحسب
كيمج انه لم يتعلم من اخطائه السابقه وهو
ما قد يعرض موسكو لهزيمه كبرى قد تهز
مكانه موسكو العسكريه
ماذا عن النجاحات التي حققها الجيش في
جورجيا والقرم وسوريا يذهب غيوم
لكونجارياس الاستاذ المشارك في جامعه
سوربون والمتخصص بقضايا الدفاع الى ان
موسكو بالغت في تقدير قوتها في اوكرانيا
وان مده التدخل القصيره والمعارضه الضعيفه
التي واجهتها روسيا في جورجيا او سوريا لم
تمنح سوى مؤشرات ضئيله للقدرات العسكريه
الفعليه للقوات الروسيه وما الحرب الروسيه
الاخيره في نظره سوى مغامره معقده ومحفوفه
بالاخطار قد تنتهي بهزيمه روسيا
في رايك هل موسكو مستعد فعليا لاي صدام
جديد مع الغرب